stephen is starting off this hour in
orlando hi stephen how are you
i'm doing good mr ramsay how are you sir
better than i deserve what's up
i gotta tell you it's an honor and i'm
almost our star starts to be talking to
you uh so bear with me
no troubles mom it turns out that um
uh colbert stress tested my stupidity
and to my surprise i was uh skinny
dipping
um i've got a call right now
that um please don't speak around me uh
it's at 26 uh that's before i even
cared to uh know you i don't know of
your radio or you
as a person um and um of course i went
through with the deal
with uh with uh with my family's i guess
support
or hey you know you don't got any credit
so you kind of have to go through with
it so
you know being reluctant than anything
you know i still sign for the car and
whatever
last that was three years ago fast
forward to today um of course kovit um
brought my employer's uh
payroll down were capped at 40 um i
based my life around
the um overtime um and basically i
am staying afloat the car keeps having
issues
um so right now basically i'm paying for
a car that's not running
um and i don't make enough to switch
you know to to pay for the repairs or
just pay for the car basically
um and forgive me if it sounds like i'm
being a victim or anything like that no
you're not you're not you're just
it's just a mess man i'm sorry you're
there i understand listen i've done lots
of stupid stuff so i know how it feels
it's no fun to be there i'm sorry you're
there okay so what's it take to fix the
car what's wrong with it
um i'll be honest with you i am
mechanically inclined um we even took uh
my family you know helped me out
uh taking the car to the dealer because
again i just wasted just about
every uh uh choice to you know fix on
the car
i spend this about 700 700 from baby
step one
and i'm i'll be really honest with you
i'm kind of hoarding those three hundred
dollars left
uh because i i'm scared to you know lose
that um
sure because i don't know when life no
what i'm asking is what does it take to
get the car repaired
well um i took it to the dealer and
they told me to fix what i already
replaced which is you know the throttle
body on the car
and i mean every place with the same
brand the you know the
the the car cars park came with
um again i think you know one thing if
it's not bad it's the other
i guess my my question is do you know
what it takes to get the car running
no okay okay that's the
first goal now is to get a mechanic or
two
get a couple of opinions and let's
figure out what it takes to get the car
running that gives
us a goal so it's not running at all
it's completely
sitting yeah how are you getting to work
uh co-workers or family how long has
this been going on
uh on and off for about a month and a
half okay
so big deal we need to get this thing in
front of a couple of different mechanics
asap
and say what's it take to get this car
running all right if it's running
once we know that all right let's just
make up a number okay i'm just going to
pick one out of the air as an example
we need a goal in other words well let's
say it takes 1200
to get it fixed well you need to find
1200
by working extra selling stuff doing all
kinds of crazy things anything you can
do
right in order to take a weekend gig
that you don't want to do but go do it
anyway
of some kind and get some money
scratched together let's get the stupid
car
fixed because it can't sell it the way
it is then once we fix it we say all
right what's the car worth what do you
think it's worth
fixed once it's running i just check it
on the kbb
um and you know best operating
conditions and whatnot
um about a thousand dollars oh it's not
worth anything
yeah okay and what do you owe on it
about
3 100 oh great news okay
super we're not fixing this car
you can probably sell it for a thousand
dollars without fixing it
most anything will bring a thousand
dollars salvage if nothing else
okay okay and then you've got to have
the 2100 now we've got a different
target so we've got to pay this off
who is the this 26 rip-off screwed you
loan with
american credit acceptance aren't they
wonderful people
just helpful they are so you need to
call american credit ripped me off
acceptance and have them accept the idea
that you need to get out of this car and
we're going to sell it
and you're going to sign an unsecured
note with them for the 2100
at the same interest rate and we're
going to sell it for a thousand
then you're going to owe them 2 100
now when that happens you no longer have
a car payment
you have a 2100 payment but you also no
longer have a car
so then our next goal is to scrape up a
thousand dollars and go buy a garage
sale car
or cash i'd be happy with that bondo
colored car you keep that's the one baby
that's the one you want that cash car
that is
ugly zero sex appeal it needs a name
you have to name it oh beth you have to
name it oh bessie
old henry i don't care what we name it
big red give it a name
because it is the car that is going to
straighten your life out
it's going to be the one you tell your
grandkids about back in the day
back in all 20 i drove old bessie you'll
be telling
that story when you're 70 years old and
that's because you're a millionaire then
yes sir all right so we're gonna get rid
of this stupid car
stupid car payment stupid acceptance i
just love the name
i'm accepting of you for 26 i'll accept
you
okay and then then we're going to get a
garage sale car and then the next goal
is get the debt paid off
and then the next goal is go get a 3 000
car which by the way
is 10 times better than a one thousand
dollar car
right and then the next goal save up and
pay cash for a ten thousand dollar car
all the while your career is getting
better you're on a budget you're doing
all the stuff you're supposed to be
doing
you can turn this around but if you let
this continue to just sit there it's
like a splinter under the skin it's just
gonna fester
you're gonna get gangrene you have all
kinds of trouble
okay so proactive get after fixing this
mess
get on the phone with these people wear
them out just wear them out
about letting you sign a note for the
difference wear them out we got to get
rid of this car
i got to get rid of this car i got to
get rid of this car worst case scenario
you just work your butt off go get you a
thousand quit paying them let it sit
there if they want it back they can have
it
right i mean what's the big deal and
then what's he gonna do repo this thing
good lord it costs them more to repo
than it's worth
they're not gonna come get it so tell
them good luck i'm not paying you right
now i'm gonna save up a thousand dollars
and go get me a little garage sale car
with a name i'm gonna get my butt back
to work get
working six jobs and get some money
and get these stupid stupid people out
of my life the good news is it's 3 100
not 31 000.
because lots of people do what you did
with 31 000
and that's harder to fix 3 100 dude
that's delivering pizzas six nights a
week for i don't know
month and a half two months you can do
it
i mean but you gotta have a car to do
that because hoofing the pizzas little
takes a while so you gotta you have to
work this out
but dude have some fun with this
bust it out hold on i'm gonna have kelly
pick up we're gonna put you in ramsey
plus for a year
as my guest put you through financial
peace university get you on every dollar
budget
i'm gonna walk with you my man i'm proud
of you you're gonna turn this around